- Like, you can bring those anywhere.
Keep them in your glove department,
keep them in your purse.
- And I'm like, do you
have one on you right now?
Because you keep talking
about how you have them.
- Actually.
(beep)
- Hi, my name is Toni.
- And I'm Tucker.
And today, we are trying each
other's breakup snack foods.
How many breakups have you been through?
- (exhales sharply) A few.
- I'm so sorry.
That really hit home, didn't it?
I honestly wish I've been through more.
This is maybe me planning
for my next breakup
or maybe first divorce.
Well, I'm excited to see
what you have in store
- So let's get to it.
- First up.
- Oh my goodness.
- Oh, a classic.
I'm ready for it.
Everyone knows that
there's two types of candy,
chocolate and not chocolate.
You gotta hit both food groups.
I can't just be wolfing down some M&M's
without having like also a sour candy.
Does that make sense?
- So which one do I eat first?
- In my household we alternate.
These are dangerous
because like once you
start, you can't stop.
And that's okay.
Like, if the breakup
didn't have those tears,
like that'll bring the tears for sure.
- I have a few questions.
- Wow. My strategy is to mask the pain
by hurting myself in another way.
It gets my mind off things.
- Yeah. Just now when I was eating them,
like I completely blacked out.
- Mission accomplish.
- Yeah. I'm not mad at it.
- Yeah.
- We'll see, we'll see.
- Tell me a little bit about
chocolate peanut butter pie Oreo.
- So they're creamy, you
get the peanut butter,
you get like a little pie and the cake,
and it's just like a really nice dessert.
- There are like nine
different methods right now
that I'm thinking of eating this.
(humming)
Oh baby.
That's the peanut butter,
that's for sure. (grunts)
Then there's a chocolate.
Makes sense with the colors.
I'm about to say something
and it's good news.
I honestly like these
better than a normal Oreo.
(Toni cheering)
I really do.
- When going through a breakup,
I feel like this is the perfect snack
because obviously it's
crunchy, it's creamy.
I don't know if I could eat all of this
and like wake up the next morning.
- Yeah, I could see myself
sobbing into these, for sure.
Are we swapping or are we keeping?
- Well, I really do really
like the whole sour thing
accompanied by the peanut chocolate thing.
- Thank you.
- I'm gonna have to go with my snack.
It feels homey and cozy
and it's what I know.
This was good though, but
I'm going back with mine.
- I respect it.
I would too.
And in terms of like
breakup, you're so right.
Something about creamy
flavor gives me breakup.
- Are we ready for the next round?
- Oh, I'm ready.
Let's do it.
- Okay.
- Let's see it.
- Let's go.
(Tucker gasping)
Obviously, it's Taco Bell.
I haven't had one of these since college.
- I haven't had one since
like three days ago.
Uncrustables, oh baby.
- So I'll go first here.
Do I just pick this up and bite this?
It's been a while.
- Absolutely.
If I saw you with a fork and knife,
I'd tackle you to the ground.
- Oh my gosh.
- Your Crunchwrap Supreme,
get rid of the beef,
add chicken instead, add jalapenos
and also fire and diablo
sauce at the same time.
Do you like spicy things?
- I do.
- It's the spice or the breakup.
That's perfect.
- That's actually nice.
- Thank you.
I didn't make it, but thank you. Wow.
- I actually really enjoy this.
- You think of breakup foods,
I immediately go to like an ice cream
or like some dessert kind of thing
but like I gotta be sobbing
the during dinner too.
The beautiful thing about a crunch wrap
is that you can eat it
and cry wherever you want,
whether that is in the car
as soon as you leave that drive through.
But me personally, I
would say on my couch,
wrapped in a blanket in
the comfort of my own home.
So I'm not kind of being
judged by those around me.
Do I try your Uncrustable?
- Yes. These are my Uncrustables.
These are peanut butter
and strawberry jelly.
That is an important detail.
You have to have them cold.
They are a perfect like
2:00 AM kind of snack
when like the tears just won't stop.
And like you just need
something quick and fast.
- I mean, you can't beat it.
It's really, it's really good.
- All right. So what are we gonna do?
Are we gonna swap?
Are we gonna keep it?
- Hmm. Okay, this is really hard for me.
These are like two
different food groups to me
but I think I have to go
with the Crunchwrap Supreme.
I mean it's a Crunchwrap Supreme.
What more can be said?
- I'm not gonna lie, this
was like really nostalgic.
I actually forgot how good this was.
- It's good.
- And I feel like it would
be a nice replacement
for the Uncrustables.
So I am actually going to keep this one.
Super tasty, yeah.
- Ooh.
Okay, should we do the next one?
- Let's do it.
Can I keep this?
Snack number three.
Boom. Oh, whoa.
- Wow. Interesting.
- Don't knock it until you try it.
That is a dill pickle, not a sweet pickle.
Get out of town if you like sweet pickles.
Don't you like sweet pickles?
Sorry.
- I do.
- No. Okay great.
- What is this doing for you?
- Oh, it's doing a lot
for me in every, oh yeah.
That was such a good bite.
Again, like you were saying with the Oreo,
you can just wolf down
like truly a full jar
and not feel bad.
Well, you'd feel bad about
the breakup still probably
but I just love a good pickle.
They're so juicy.
You get that salt.
- How many of these are
you eating in one sitting?
- Do I have to be honest?
Probably like eight.
(Toni shouting)
I feel like that's not
as many as it sounds.
When you're going through a breakup,
I feel like I need something
from every food group.
You need that sweet, you need that savory.
And this kind of hits one
of the other food groups.
- Yeah, I could see that.
I really do like the dill in the pickle.
- There we go.
- Yeah, I'm open.
- Can I try your Paws?
- Of course.
- How do you eat it?
Are you grabbing by the fist
- I mean, yeah, I'm fisting these Paws.
- Yow, baby.
Here we go.
- Obviously when you're
going through a breakup,
you're looking for anything
to just like to distract you
and get your mind off of things.
So like the shape, like really
is a little bit entertaining.
- I totally agree with you.
Just like having a little fun thing.
It's like, (imitate crying)
and I look down and I go, okay.
It is a brief moment of levity.
- I like submitted an inquiry
for them to make the hot flavor.
They haven't got back to me yet.
Cheetos.
- You submitted an inquiry?
- Yeah.
- I love that.
- So, what are you gonna do?
Are you sticking with your snack?
Are you sticking with
the dill pickle thingy?
- You know, as much as I love a pickle.
I'm gonna have to go with the Paws.
This just feels more break-upy.
Like, holding this here.
(Tucker crying)
(Toni laughing)
- Exactly.
- You know?
- What about you?
What are you keeping?
- (exhales sharply)
While I love the pickle,
it's not giving breakup, sad, depressed.
So, I'm going with my Paws.
- And I respect that.
- Yeah.
- Are you gonna finish that one?
- No, go ahead.
- Okay, thank you.
- Let's do the next round.
- Let's do it.
- Ready?
- Yes.
- Freddy?
- Oh my goodness.
- Whoa. Honey Bun.
I don't think I've had a Honey Bun.
No offense.
- Oh my goodness.
You haven't lived.
- It looks to me like a cinnamon roll
- Sort of, something like that.
- (humming) Oh baby.
Are you kidding me?
- This is the breakfast
morning breakup snack.
This is like before I pretend
like I'm gonna go work out,
I'm gonna eat a bite of
that, have a little coffee.
- This is wild because like one bite
and it's melting in my mouth.
- They're like super small and compact.
You can put them in like
your shirt, your sweater,
in your hair.
- Okay. Do these come wrapped?
I now have to ask.
- Yeah, they do come wrapped.
- Okay, great.
And you're so right.
I need to be sobbing at breakfast too.
And this is the perfect way to do so.
- Always portable, like you
can bring those anywhere
and keep them in your glove compartment,
keep them in your purse.
- And I'm like, do you
have one on you right now?
Because you keep talking
about how you have them.
- Actually.
- Gone Berry Crazy.
Dark chocolate.
- So these are in the freezer
section at Trader Joe's.
- TJ's does it again.
- They really do.
They done did it again.
Are you a dark chocolate kind of person?
- Yes.
I am.
- You look like you just
got over the breakup,
I'll tell you what.
- I actually really love these.
It is like, okay, I'm over it, I'm done.
- Yes. It reminds me of what's to come.
- It's not healthy, but
like we're getting there.
- I mean, I'm no doctor,
- We're getting there.
but dark chocolate, to me, in
my lived experience, healthy.
A strawberry, that's what we call a fruit.
Are we swapping or are we keeping?
What do you wanna do?
- I'm gonna keep it real.
Honey Buns, like I grew up on those.
I just feel like I have surpassed that,
I'm ready to give them up.
- Oh, I did not expect that.
- I'm ready to move on.
- I think that I also am gonna go
with the berry, very,
berry, cherry, very, very.
- The cherry, very, Gary, very?
- See, you get so confused when
trying to say the name of it
that you forget about your ex.
- Next one, are you ready?
- Let's do it.
- All right. Come on.
- Oh my gosh.
That's the cutest thing I've ever seen.
- Chocolate milk?
Is this what this is?
- Not chocolate milk.
Chocolate milk.
- I can't say that I'm super
excited about this one,
if I'm gonna be honest.
So like, what's the deal?
- You gotta remember that
snack is not only food form.
I gotta be drinking something
while I'm wolfing down on
my drumsticks, you know.
(Tucker laughing)
- Bizarre.
- It's kind of thick, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- It's like a viscous fluid,
but it's delicious.
- All right, I accept that.
How about we try the cones?
- Okay.
- You do what you want.
I usually eat a few of these at a time.
So this is like, okay,
I'm going to binge
watch my favorite series
and I'm gonna eat like 10 of these.
You don't feel bad about
eating like 50 of them.
- And again, I am distracted
by how cute and fun they are.
- Yeah.
- I don't even remember my ex.
- All right. So what are we gonna do?
Are we gonna swap?
Are we gonna keep it?
Obviously, I think you know where I'm at.
- I think I do.
- I'm eyeing my cones.
What are you doing? What are you doing?
I'm curious.
- Okay. This is hard.
I'm trying to look back
at all the other snacks
that I've had.
And again, I kind of,
and standing by the fact
that you need a liquid.
So I think I'm gonna go with a liquid.
But these are delicious.
Okay. That was all of them.
This was so fun though,
thank you all for joining us.
And let us know what your
favorite breakup snack food is.
- Yeah, comment below, tell us.
- Thanks for hanging out with us.
- Thank you.
- Bye.
- You're gonna get through this.
You are, don't worry.
Okay?
- We've all been there.
- [Tucker] You're better off without them.
(Toni and Tucker laughing)
(soft upbeat music)